The snark left discord is being
massively overblown, okay? There's like
eight people there total who aren't
worthless. But Destiny has done so much
worse to us.
He doxxed us.
You are so
stupid. Destiny was doxxing people long
before this discord ever existed. You
rat.
>> [music]
>> Brief introduction of his POV.
What am I doing today? Okay, what are my
goals? What are you doing today? guys.
What do I plan to do? So, I plan to kind
of showcase what's what the snarkers do,
how they do it,
and
the tactics they use. Because at the end
of the day, I don't have a complete set
of information. I don't. I don't have
access to the logs or the discords or
anything like that, right? I have seen
some information.
I have some pieces of the puzzle, but I
don't have a complete picture.
So, I can't make any specific like
J Soc did this on this day at this time
at this place, and he sent this DM to
that. I don't I don't I just don't have
that. I cannot make that claim, right?
Okay. What I just want to know what what
evidence you do have.
That's like about it.
Cuz it sounds to me like a picture of
Vic was put put somewhere, and he's lost
his mind over it.
He thinks like that information being in
that discord proves that this discord
has been like a nest of doxxing or
something, despite a bunch of people in
there saying it's obviously not that.
But hey, we keep going.
>> What I can do,
and what I think will help, and what I
think will hurt them,
and it really will,
is point out how they operate.
And once you
once once once it's made known to you,
you're going to see it everywhere, man.
You're going to see it
all over.
Right? Because they do it most of it in
the open, right? They don't make a
secret of it.
>> Okay. Right? And you'll see the op.
And when you see it,
you'll be like, "Oh, a lot of things
will make sense." Right? A lot of things
will make sense.
>> Okay.
>> Because they prey on ignorance.
They're like little roaches.
They hide in the dark, okay?
I don't think that at all. Shining a
light on what they do
makes it harder for them to do what they
do.
Shining a light on what we do actually
just gives us viewers and followers and
more power. So, thank you, Wick, for
contributing to the team.
>> to talk about it. We're going to go
through it, okay?
If I could see how if Wick thought
that's what's happening, that Wick
would, in his head, think he's helping,
right?
But we have the truth. We have the
arguments.
The truth is on our side. You know what
I'm saying? So, if you send people to me
and they ask me questions and I just
show them exactly why I might not like
somebody or what exactly I think
somebody's done wrong,
well,
I just win. I just win there. So, thank
you. Please continue shining a light,
Wick. And me and Duce Highly Cyan, or
however you say your name, I do
appreciate it.
So, at the end of the day, why am I
doing this or what what was the
catalyst? If you haven't heard, I got
doxxed, gang.
Again.
So, this isn't the first time I've been
Right? Okay.
>> But the last time it happened, it
happened like as a group.
Right? A bunch of us got all doxxed at
the same time. So, it felt little
it felt different, right? It felt
different. And I knew it happened when
it happened.
Right? I knew that okay, this happened,
but I can kind of I could kind of hide
behind the larger creators a little bit,
right? And kind of keep it on the down
low, and not really
You could have kept it on the down low
here. You just went and and acknowledged
it and yelled about it this time, right?
Like you This time you've just gone and
yelled about it. This doesn't help you.
You could have kept your head down this
time, too, if you wanted to.
But, it's fine.
If you If you have some If you think
it's important to stand up and say this
happened to me,
okay.
>> talk about a little bit and kind of
slide through.
This time feels different. And And one
of the reasons is is not just me that
got targeted.
But, it's
it was Tally.
Um I talked to them and got permission
to say what I'm going to say, okay? We
had a little powwow, okay? And uh we
decided it is better that people know
and
understand
just how this has gone.
Um so, Tally got okay.
Stardust got
And for Tally, specifically,
uh they found her full name.
Uh they found the place where she works.
Uh they found Dude, this is This is a
truly insane thing to do.
I'm sorry.
There's no reason I feel bad for the
people who have been
Like
did to accept it doing this. This is a
wild thing to start putting out there on
the record.
No Nothing by the way, nothing nothing
here has been published by that snark
left group. None of it was even The
things he's describing currently were
even found by that group, okay? The
thing that happened in the Discord, and
I do think it was a tweet that featured
a picture of Wick and his name, and it
was archived by a bot.
To pretend that this level of
information gathering was going on in
the Discord is totally insane.
It was like somebody put a a tweet in,
and I have no idea the context, but like
they deleted the message, and then once
we found out that that was put in there,
we banned the person who did it. It's
It's insane. There's nothing close to
what's happening in other places, and we
have nothing to do with that. So
>> information on her wife Or at least, you
know, to my knowledge, we have nothing
There's not no connection at all, right?
You would have to give me an idea of a
connection. I have no knowledge of any
connection. They
No, I I'm obviously not omniscient. If
somebody has like a a different username
and is operating as an anonymous person
in a different place, I can't prevent
that unless I'm told about it. So if
somebody has evidence of that, please
reach out.
>> released her address of her workplace,
right?
And they made it explicitly known that
they were looking for her home address
on uh Zillow for a  complete
doxx, right?
Um And they'd done this months ago,
right?
I didn't know about it.
But But it happened. They want to keep
us from talking in the One of the
biggest, I guess, weapons that the
snarkers and snarker-adjacent
communities have
besides anonymity, right? They It They
They We're going to talk about one of
the core concepts we're going to talk
about is plausible deniability and how
they operate in kind of like a cellular
structure and how they operate like a
They have cross-pollinated communities.
This is why nobody intelligent is on
board anymore, right? Because you
essentially have to operate in a way You
have to tell this story that requires a
level of oversight over communities
that is impossible in the internet, like
entirely impossible, right? We can't go
around and figure out what other
Discords every person in a Discord is
in, right? Like it's
Like you want me to stop somebody who's
under an anonymous username from making
a different anonymous account and
operating somewhere else, or be aware of
it. How the is that possible, buddy?
Um I do want to, before we get into the
meat, because this happened uh this
happened after I made my outline, but I
wanted to insert it because it's worth
talking about.
Um, let's talk about Counter-Points.
Counter-Points should not have done what
he did. Um,
going out in public and basically
putting other people's business on blast
like that was very inappropriate. And
that's even dis- That That's even
disassociating
We're not going to do any analysis of
that situation at all.
Are we not going to do Not even a little
bit. Not a Not even a tiny bit of
analysis of that situation.
Okay. Dude, we have to actually go back
and watch it because some people are
suggesting that what happened was Connor
was referencing the Lauren stuff in a
way that could go back to the 2022 leaks
or 2023 leaks, whenever that was. Right?
People are suggesting that that's what
Connor was referring to. Like he was He
was doing it in an in an ambiguous way,
right? That couldn't be blamed on him.
And then Destiny leaked the dating
currently. If that's how it went, then
Connor wasn't leaking public stuff. It
was Destiny leaking that publicly,
right? At least with regards to Lauren.
Being it from it from like the streamer
drama, the the friendship dynamics
there, right? Putting out like other
people's
well, escapades and um,
dating
statuses on blast just because you're
mad at a friend and you want to hurt him
with it,
all the while saying that you're doing
it as a tough love tactic,
you're you're turning other people's
business into like a a weapon, man, into
a bullet. It's
highly inappropriate. That's just not
something you do.
Into [__] You don't You don't talk to
friends like that in public. Why did
Destiny lie about his relationship with
Lauren Southern to try to get an own on
Connor in that conversation? You don't
talk to friends like that in public.
I just I literally don't get it.
I and there's this weird
Dude, should we just go like fully
skits? So this is weird psychopathic
thing Destiny
I think does. Man, I it's hard for me to
show you perfect proof of this. I think
he quite often lets people know things
in private in a way that they have to
dance around it in public and he will
even press on them to dance around it in
public, right? Like he will let people
know things in private that they
shouldn't have shared or they shouldn't
share and then he will intentionally
make an argument trying to pressure them
into like basically saying, well, you
could totally beat me if you reveal the
truth right now.
You totally beat beat me if you reveal
the truth right now. Will you? Will you?
Will you or won't you? Will you or won't
you? Will you or won't you? It's It's
straight up psychotic [__]
It's wild. It's anyway.
And we won't get a commentary on that
either from Wick, okay?
Cuz Wick is in the Destiny's a massive
victim here. Destiny is the eternal
victim.
God. Like this isn't This isn't like a
something you do with a friend in
public. You If that had been a private
conversation that they had, where he
wanted to be like, man, you're [__]
up your life cuz you're doing XYZ. You
What are you doing, man? Like there or
is this like you I can see instances
where that would be entirely appropriate
that where it might even be the right
thing to do, right? Um and again, I
don't I don't know in their entire
dynamic, so please keep that
you know, take it with a grain of salt,
right? I don't I don't know their
uh I don't know the truth claims of what
he was claiming and what he wasn't,
right? I don't know. But yeah, you don't
do that [__] in public. That's just not
okay. That's just not okay, man.
What's going on? But I get it, like a
lot of pressure. Um there's a lot of
different incentives. There's a lot of
different um people pushing you one
direction or another. And that on top of
the personal [__] you're going through,
again, give some grace. But I still kind
of like this this It's kind of gross. Uh
it felt gross. I tried to stop it. Uh I
tried to get the I tried to calm down. I
tried to kind of
get everyone to de-escalate
This is, by the way, how like this
Destiny's favorite situation where he
has like so- some friends who don't know
the whole truth that Connor does, and
they're all putting themselves out there
in a way that they would be totally
humiliated if the full truth comes out.
Right?
Like they're totally defending him. They
have no idea what happened with Connor,
what set him off. And Destiny's got them
all right. This is like his ideal
scenario right now, right? He's got so
many friends who if they hear the whole
truth, they'll be totally humiliated.
They could be totally humiliated in
public.
And he's like got other people who knew
part of the truth, and now the friends
who know nothing are attacking the
people who know the truth. Further
pressuring them to tell the truth.
And Destiny just has to sit back and
watch.
Uh just to summarize kind of like the
intro portion here,
cuz I'm getting a little long-winded. Uh
people need to understand what tactics
are being used, so you can see and
understand how
how none of this is is real in a real
sense. None of it's real It's all fake
and gay, to to borrow a phrase.
Um these are all astroturfed, though.
Lying.
Like you're you're straight up lying.
>> narratives that are going around. These
are all Like they make it look like it's
organic, and people are just naturally
feeling this way, but no, they're not.
These are talking points that are
manufactured, that are boosted, that an
organization like like with
organizations are clipping and shipping
and
um
all of this
Clipping and shipping. Or it's like 100
people. Well, like four of them are not
worthless.
I'm sorry.
This The Snark Left Discord is being
massively overblown, okay? There's like
eight people there total who aren't
worthless. Holy sh-
How are we PRETENDING THIS? WHAT ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT right now? I'm just
kidding, by the way. Lots There's 100
totally loyal, totally psychopathic
mujahideen soldiers, okay?
Obviously, but
Come on, man.
This is so It's We have to be blown up
into something that's so crazy. We're
like 1/10,000
the Clavicular Operation.
What are we talking about, man? This is
astroturfed in a very real way, and
we're going to get to that.
Um I want to talk about
who's at fault.
This is one of those things where I
can't give you solid answers because I
don't know. And I want to make that
clear what I'm saying and what I'm not
saying. I have suspicions based on the
evidence that I have seen.
There's a couple people who I know,
but uh you don't get to know that
information yet.
Uh but for like other people,
it's just suspicion at this point,
but I am fairly confident that [snorts]
as more information comes out, some of
my suspicions will be will be confirmed.
But I just want to make sure that
everyone knows that I'm not making any
specific
accusations against specific people
unless I say their specific name, okay?
So if you're sitting there thinking,
"Why is he attacking me?"
There's this evil amorphous blob, dude.
I There's got to be like a like a
fantasy or anime reference here, okay?
Like There's this amorphous invisible
blob that just attacks
attacks streamers, guys, and it's like
all powerful, but I'm not blaming
anybody for it.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude. Did I say your name?
Then, I mean, maybe if you're part of
these groups,
uh but I don't know if you're part of
these groups or not.
Does that make sense?
We got it? We're on the same page here?
Um one of the biggest pieces of the
puzzle that I've received
is when
Destiny and Dan and Mouton and all those
people were saying, "Hey,
this server has has a doxx in it. Has
doxxes in it."
And the people who were
uh
doxxes
What?
>> snark team and the snark side kept
saying, "No, they don't. No, you're
lying. That's not true. We don't
I use This is the lowest IQ trap to fall
into, man. This is exactly why I'm like
So, I try to be so careful, man, cuz
they think this is like good proof of
anything, right? I'm going to make a
universal claim.
I'm going to I'm I'm going to force you
to make some universal claim. This has
never happened.
Even though it's obvious you could never
say that this has never happened, even
though anybody with an above room
temperature IQ can see that if you say,
"I've never been somewhere where people
have been doxxed." That means I've never
seen someone get doxxed anywhere I've
ever been. Like this never happened,
right?
Even though everybody knows that,
and they go, "Oh, well, look at this."
It's like, dude, one message was
deleted, so not even searchable. Like
It's There's so many things going on
with regards to the the tweet that Wicks
referring to, right?
Like the the lowest IQ
total mouth-breathing
waste of existence. This fools them.
This this tricks them.
Dude, it's so dumb. That's why I have to
try to keep doing the "Oh, to my
knowledge, not to my knowledge. Oh, as
far as I know." Because if I If I say
that,
then I could get clipped somewhere like
saying something they'll go, "Oh, look.
This guy said that nobody ever typed the
hard R in in that Discord, but here's a
log from 8 months ago where where where
it happened." It's like, "Well, okay.
Well, it's deleted. I couldn't search
for it." Do you know what I mean?
It's a totally insane bar for people to
be speaking at.
And for the other side, it's like, "We
have real substantial evidence of
like
actual wrongdoing that causes actual
harm in the world."
Anyway, that's people we have no doxxes
in my in our server. None of that's
true. Silly combo. I was shown evidence.
Destiny was telling the truth.
And the people who were telling me that
the snark server had none of this and
that were lying. And
it caused me to reevaluate my priors,
right?
And the credibility of Destiny has shot
up in my estimation.
It's just shot up. He was He was just
correct. This is just true. What he said
was just true, and I know it.
Um
the people who told me that there was
nothing in the snark server, their
credibility is shot with me. I'm like,
"I don't trust you anymore."
And some of these people I trusted.
You just wanted to be on that side. It's
totally fine, but it's obvious you just
wanted to be on that side, Wick.
Like you're just embarrassing yourself
with this.
You You just want to be on that side,
which is whatever. Okay, you You're too
stupid. This is a lot of the other thing
going on is people are like stale. They
just want to be with like the biggest
bully who they think will win, right?
They don't really have the capacity to
evaluate information or make informed
decisions of their own. So, they find
the guy who's the just the biggest
bully, who's bullied everybody else,
who's won every time before, and they're
going to ride with that guy.
Right? Like they've watched these
manifestos drop before, and you see this
in DGG, right? Manifestos coming is just
trust the plan. Or like
>> [laughter]
>> for whatever the Destiny community has
become, okay? It's just trust the plan.
And yeah, he's just going to he's going
to stick with the big bully that's won
on this on this kind of conflict before.
He's not going to look into who's right.
He doesn't care. He just wants this side
to win. And realistically, I'm guessing
a lot of the rest of this stream is
going to go into his reasoning for that,
which is he got bullied by like spicy
chatter or something. Like he really
That's probably what it is. Like he got
bullied by some spicy chatters who made
fun of him, made fun of his teeth, made
fun of him taking 2 years to go and go
to the dentist and get his teeth fixed.
And that's going to be what pushed him
in this direction.
Like the only thing that pushed him in
this direction.
I'm not joking. It It is that simple. It
is that pathetic. It is that sad.
That's just it. did Right? I really did.
I was like, man, okay. Your word? I'll
take your word.
I'll take your word. And that's why like
I was skeptical. I was keeping neutral
cuz I had competing people who both I I
had some level of trust for
um were telling me different things. I
was like, okay. I don't know. I haven't
seen it.
But no, it's like after seeing
Uh yeah. I feel like this is This is
what I'm trying to communicate, Dobby.
Yes, it's about the other side wronging
him on a personal level. And so he
doesn't like them, doesn't want to be
with them. So he's always wanted to be
on that side. And this finally gives him
some like explanation he can give other
people. Unfortunately, a lot of the
other people who care and look into
things, they can all see exactly what's
going on.
>> Seeing that, yeah. Okay. This person was
tell This person was honest with me, was
up front with me, and this person was a
flyer?
Crazy work.
Okay.
Puzzle pieces coming to place. Click.
Click. Click.
There are three main concepts that I
think that we have to uh
we have to under Well, four main
concepts, I should say, that we have to
understand.
Huh? One of them, the first I I I I want
you to understand
so that you can understand the tactics
and understand the space and understand
how these works, is how legitimate
actions
can become illegitimate in certain
contexts, Okay? How an action that would
normally be just fine, nothing wrong
with it, it's just how it is, when
paired with other legitimate actions,
can turn into something sinister. Uh
An example, driving in your car, just
fine.
Totally fine if you're a white person,
totally wrong if you're a black person.
Right, Wick? Let's go.
>> places as long as you abide the speed
limit, who cares, right? Um obey the
rules of the road, you're fine.
But when you have 10 cars all driving
and coordinating together to block a
road
and slow down traffic, that's different.
Each of the individual actions that
these people are doing perfectly
legitimate.
But the coordination
and their goals and how they use the
actions becomes illegitimate. Does that
make sense?
I'm immediate counter example.
There's nine people doing it instead of
10. One of them is stuck in the gridlock
around those 10, right?
Can you use an RPG to blow up that car?
Right? Cuz this is again the whole thing
that's happening here is they're
basically blaming they're they're saying
coordination is happening because they
feel like some certain groups work
together. That they feel like the output
is the outcome that they're seeing in
their lives is negative and caused by
these groups in aggregate. So they
think, well, you guys are coordinating.
That is not necessarily like that's not
that doesn't even remotely follow,
right?
That's just not the case. That's doesn't
even remotely follow.
So then you have to ask, is it okay to
attack anybody who you perceive just
because of your perception of them being
involved in that outcome? Is that is
that okay? Like if I get punched in the
face and it's captured in like a TikTok
short and people laugh at it, are those
people who laugh at it, can I hit one of
them back? Can I find one one person who
left a comment going, "Ha, I love
watching this guy get hit in the face."
Can I go and hit that person in the
face? Right? There has to be
some way of mapping someone's actions
onto the consequences for those actions.
But I think they are explicitly
endeavoring to like disconnect these
things. Another analogy. I got a few. I
wrote a couple down.
Uh light a match, okay?
You light a match uh to light your
cigarette, uh light a candle, um if it's
dark out and you want to get some light.
Nothing wrong with that, right?
Perfectly legitimate.
Perfectly fine. Nothing will happen.
But if you light a match next to a gas
leak,
even though it's the same action,
because it's done in a different
environment, in a different context, you
have a different result.
And the snarkers have been pumping
pumping gas into every chat room, every
voice call, every comment section,
where
normal normal actions, normal things,
suddenly have explosive results.
Okay.
Apparently we dude. And they'll hide
behind the legitimate portion, right? Or
the the legitimate thing. They'll They
want you to focus on the bricks, so you
can't see the wall, okay? And they'll
hide behind that. They'll That's the
tactic that they'll do, right? Um that
they'll say, "Well, anyone can drive.
I'm just driving, man. There's nothing
wrong with driving. Are you trying to
stop my right to drive?"
Of course I could just drive. I'm just a
Ameri- like I'm a citizen, right? I am a
citizen of the internet. We could all
just drive, right? But they're all doing
it together to block you, right? They're
all driving to block you in.
Um uh none of this is a thing of All of
the people who dislike me are ACTING IN
COORDINATION. Nobody could possibly
There's no way this many people could
like could dislike me
without it being coordinated. Better one
a better analogy would be something like
shooting a mugger compared to carrying a
weapon to shoot a specific person before
you knew they were going to mug someone.
Well, there there's a lot of analogies
we need to discuss. So, those are the
ones I chose. Maybe there's better ones,
but those are the ones that I went with,
okay?
We're not going to be perfect here
today. But yes, they And they'll mock
it, too. Like, "This guy's just talking
about This guy's just talking about All
he's All we're doing is a It's a clip
channel, bro. It's a clip channel.
That's all it is.
That's all It's just a clip channel."
Which is fine in normal contexts, but
when it's coordinated, targeted, edited
out of context, meant to meant to target
specific people for a specific purpose,
uh meant driven and boosted and all
these things, it can become harassment.
Show me that. Even though Show me that
now, Wick.
Show me that now. the context around it,
why you're doing it, to what purpose, to
what end
can become harassment.
Uh
um so yeah, that's a concept that I
think you need to understand the first
two, how legitimate actions can become
illegitimate in different contexts, and
how coordination matters.
They want every step judged in isolation
because each step sounds defensible in
isolation. But harassment campaigns are
not built out of one giant indefensible
act. They are built out of many small
defensible acts arranged towards an
indefensible purpose.
Example, a streamer makes a messy
comment during a free hour broadcast. A
hostile viewer clips 15 seconds of it.
That viewer posts it in a server
dedicated to attacking that streamer.
The server agrees uh the server uh like
they they do like they're They
manufacture talking points, agrees on
the harshest possible interpretation.
The members of that server begin posting
the clip with similar captions, uh
similar hashtags, all these things.
Members begin um sending it out to other
streamers that may or may not be not be
connected right? I want I do want to get
into another core concept later, the and
another tactic they use, the plausible
deniability, the they use unrelated
actors to further their goals uh as part
of the machine even though these other
unrelated actors do not realize that
they are part of the machine, right? Um
the they go in and they react to it into
the context of it as if it's already
settled, right? Like this is obviously
what it means. Um there is no other
interpretation. If you have another
interpretation, you're stupid, etc. And
then people will go in and send people
into these chats of streamers reacting
to it that may or may not be part of the
machine, or the streamers themselves
that they're clipping to stir, right? To
get reactions for more clips, to uh
spread it even around anymore, to kind
of create this this narrative that they
can use to serve their purpose, right?
And all of And all of these acts by
themselves might be defensible in
different contexts, right? Well, there's
nothing wrong with clipping people.
There's nothing wrong with giving your
opinion. There's nothing wrong with
reacting to and giving a take like Wick
sucks, the Wick handled that bad, right?
There's nothing wrong uh even bad about
boosting your friends. Like if your
friend wants you to boost their clip,
nothing wrong with that in isolation.
Right? But it's the coordination. And
they'll start tagging the streamer's
guests. They'll start sending it to the
streamer's sponsors and say, "Is this
your boy? Look at what your boy said
about Israel Pal Tide. You're going to
You're going to let him say that?" What?
And when the streamer gets angry or
defensive because they'll see it
happening,
that's clipped, too.
And it's used to push, right? The
narrative, stress the target out so that
they make mistakes, and it's a whole
system. Okay? And remember, this is the
goal.
Love the Snark Server.
They have targets.
It's not just Destiny, by the way.
Ethan Klein, uh few others. They've
targeted Hutch, they've targeted Loaded
Box, I believe.
Um I don't I don't know the full target
list. I don't have access to the logs,
right? But they have targets.
I again,
are we pretending that the entire Twitch
anti-Semitism thing didn't happen or
what Like, you're literally just
describing the Twitch anti-Semitism
campaign, directly, one-to-one. They
like perfect description of the Twitch
anti-Semitism campaign. Like, directly,
with no substitutes whatsoever.
They weren't just going after Hasan,
they were going after the people around
him.
Dan going around like showing everybody
the caller, doing the research, take you
to Loaded Box, take you to Hutch. What
What are you guys mad? Are Are
Are you guys mad about like copyright
infringement, IP infringement? What is
the What is the allegation?
You guys are doing the thing we do, and
we really hate it. Like, okay. I Okay.
Cry about it. Targets.
And they are targeting them. They
targeted me.
Right?
So, that's that's how it's happening,
right? And again, they'll retreat to the
They'll want every aspect judged in
isolation, and they'll retreat to that,
and they'll be like, "Bro, we're just
clipping. What's wrong with clipping?"
Because it hides and obfuscates the
scale of what they're doing and the real
purpose of what they're doing, which is
to harass and jaywalk. And yes, I'm
naming names, has called for the mass
reporting of different targets. And
that's a lie, or show where I've called
to mass report somebody other than
Destiny.
You just said different targets. I've
called for the mass reporting of
different targets.
What? And he has used this system of
harassment and coordination to create
the justification Do him? No, it's just
funny.
>> where he can call for that, where he
makes others feel justified in taking
that action.
I can't give you the details of every
single thing that he's done to do that.
But he has admitted to that to calling
for the mass reporting of people. And
you have to remember
Destiny. Just Destiny.
And it took I like the bar is so
insanely high. I've explained where the
bar is, and nobody would actually be
upset or disagree with that bar.
That's the problem. Right? That this is
the goal, okay? The goal isn't to get to
the truth.
They aren't mass reporting because
they've done something right.
Because they've organically done
something
They're mass reporting
The [__] What should happen? They've
done something right.
Because they've organically
done something
Sorry, just the way that came out was so
odd.
They're mass reporting because they hate
them.
Right?
They hate them. So, they're building a
permission structure. They're building
up
Okay, it's so annoying to me that you
guys will just
It's Okay, this actually does piss me
off. This is the way you start me. If
you just watch my stream and repeat back
every single one of my arguments, but
try to make them about me without
understanding why I was making them or
without any of the conduct being
similar, that is actually a way to start
me, okay? When you go and take every
argument I've had and throw it back at
me with no underlying factual basis,
that's
crazy.
Stop. Stop.
>> to say why what they are doing against
the people that they hate is righteous
and just.
It's a coordination campaign.
It's what it is. It's AstroTurf. It's
like um it's like
Trump sending out
>> [snorts]
>> uh to all the people in
uh the group chats on Maga side um
after his like third assassination
attempt that they we have to build the
ballroom. Okay? They want it to feel
organic.
But it's not.
It's AstroTurfed. It's not organic at
all.
And remember a lot of each each of the
people individuals in this this server
not all of them share the same level of
guilt. And I want to make that clear,
right? Um
if you're just in the server, who the
[__] cares?
I don't.
But if you've been part of this
coordination, if you've been involved
to certain degrees, the more involved
you are
the more culpability I feel that you
have. Bleak. Bleak, man. Extremely
bleak.
>> uh thank you for the example. Uh GregZ2
says Wictor V, if there are levels to
it, what level of culpable are you are
you for Destiny and DGG doxing? So, I
guess we're going to We have a couple
more core points to get to you, but this
is a good example of one of the major
main tactics that Nux Taku uses. Um
asking you why you're criticizing
something if it's an internal critique.
If you just want to do an internal
critique, that's fine. If you want to
say, but you to to specify that it's an
internal critique, Wictor would have to
go, "Well, I don't have a problem with
my friends doing it. I only have a
problem with my enemies doing it cuz
they say they they don't want to do it."
I'm just making a hypocrisy point,
right? If that's all you want to do, to
an internal critique of their position,
it shows inconsistency on their part.
Then you have to you have to
differentiate yourself and say, "No, no,
no, I disagree with that. I think this
is okay."
That's what you have to say. Address
both sides of it and it's fine. Always,
always, always be on offense.
If someone is talking about what you're
doing, what about Destiny? And And
people are going to react to this. And
this is This is what they will say.
Right? The I will make an accusation. I
will speak about what they're doing in
the I don't want doxxing happening
around me. I don't want I don't want to
be in communities with people who doxx
with any frequency. I disavow it.
I do think there's some capacity for
people to change. Like if they've if
they've done something like post some
[__] a year ago, two years ago, three
years ago, depending on like obviously,
I would never want somebody around who
has, hmm, how would I put it? I
personally, yeah, I think there's like a
sliding scale there on forgiveness, but
it's an immediate ban. It's an immediate
disavowal. And we never let that stuff
stay. I think there was an example in my
Discord of like somebody who'd put
someone's name in the chat cuz they were
in a relationship. And they like broke
up, and it was really messy. And after a
year, I think we unbanned that guy.
I'm okay with that. They're They like
talk now, and it's like not a big deal.
That's okay. That Like I'm okay with
that.
Probably the The closest I've come to
breaking this is the Shamu thing. But
the Shamu thing's a little different in
that I understand he was in a space
where that was like on the the table, a
part of the playing field in that space,
which I think is gross, but he left and
doesn't want to do that anymore, right?
It's a very different thing. Yeah.
Anyway, that's how I feel about it.
>> The The wrongs that they are doing, the
the bad things that they are doing. And
wait for it, and you'll hear it. What
about Destiny? What about DGG? What
about all these other people? What about
everything else? And it's a way to
always, always, always be on offense
because they want you to listen
Just do both sides of it. Like I don't I
don't want that [__] around me. I want
those people banned. I want those people
not around me at all, right? But now
that I've I've I've defended my side of
it, right? Cuz I don't think you should
ever be scared of defending your side.
Sometimes if somebody's weaponizing that
disingenuously, right? If they never,
ever, ever want to speak on it, they
never, ever, ever want to speak for what
their, you know, their people do, or
what their their community does, or what
they do personally, they only want to
attack, that's when it's bad.
But I'm totally fine explaining like my
position, how I feel about it.
Litigating and Connor counterpoints to
this I don't know if he did this on
purpose or just he just mind raped as
Destiny likes to say. Um instead of
talking about what the snarkers were
doing he wanted to litigate Destiny's
life.
What does that have anything to do with
what we are talking about? Nothing. But
I The reason that Connor got onto
Destiny's life is because Destiny was
saying
what you're you're only litigating
things bad decisions I made years ago.
Destiny knows that Connor knows about
incredibly risky behavior he was
engaging in as of I believe it's
November 2025 and then as of a week ago
or two weeks ago.
Wick, you
slobbering
That is what Connor was upset about was
he was saying he was litigating
something and trying to leave Destiny
off the hook and Destiny's going, "All
this is in the past. All this is in the
past. Why are you so crazy, Connor? Why
are you like losing your mind right
now?" When Destiny knew fully well why
Connor was upset in this precise moment
in time.
That's what it was. You're acting like
for no reason Connor brought this up.
You are not even remotely analyzing the
reason for it.
Why would that be? Why would you want to
so so
desperately run from the truth, the fact
of the matter?
One can only speculate. People feel the
need to defend themselves. People feel
the need to be like answer to explain.
But if you're excusing, you're losing.
In the red court war, right? So, that's
the first tactic. Always always always
always always always always attack.
Never ever ever ever make the
conversation about what's happening on
the doxing server or the snark server or
with Jstark or with all these other
I've like explicitly just done all of
these things. Oh, I would love to know
what's happening with me cuz I've I've
literally gone and explained what
happened
specifically. I've no problem explaining
what happened. The people always always
always always make the conversation what
about Destiny? What is Destiny doing?
What is DGG doing? That's the first and
most important tactic that I need you
guys to understand.
I need you to understand it. And this
isn't a conspiracy.
By the way, if you're going to get mad
about me reporting, I'm afraid the
conversation does have to go to what
Destiny's doing. You'd be a
to not understand that. F.I. Douching
Maliciousness says, "What is Destiny
doing?" Right now, Wick, you're
streaming, but what is Destiny doing?
Oh, that's a good question. I have no
[__] clue. F.I. Douching the Witches
Persona says, "Classic Darvo, the same
as Maga, just replace Destiny with
Biden." True.
Oh, also, another really important point
is is like you can't disconnect this
from Destiny and Dan being the people
leaking these logs, right? So, when Wick
says, "Well, I can see pieces, but I
can't see the whole picture."
Okay, so you're just taking their word
for it? You can't rely on Destiny and
Dan's word and then say, "Well, don't
talk to me about what Destiny said or
done."
You can't do that.
Right? Obviously, that is of another
just incredibly dim-witted position to
have. Um I'm going to take these
people's word for something,
but if you ask me about their conduct,
I'm not going to be I'm going to say
that you're just attacking them. You're
like trying to what about to them.
No, Wick, your allegation is based
substantially on their word, taking
their word for it.
So, like I'll give you I'll give you an
analogy.
You have a factory owner who's who's
built a machine, okay, or who's helped
to build a machine.
They may not personally operate the
machine, but if he designed the factory,
if he ignored the safety warnings, if he
rewarded speed over caution, if he
punished people who complained about it,
He like chat GPT together a whole thing
here. Very cool.
Very, very cool.
Uh I Wait.
Wait, wouldn't this Hold on. I I don't
want to say it before I think about it.
Wait, let me let me go back here. I'll
give you I'll give you an analogy. Hold
on. Let me listen to this again. who's
built a machine, okay, or who's helped
to build a machine.
They may not personally operate the
machine, but if he designed the factory,
if he ignored the safety warnings, if he
rewarded speed over caution, if he
punished people who complained about it,
he be
Oh, it's the infinite machine. It's
literally the infinite work I didn't
want to say it before I could go back
and listen to it again, but he's
describing President Sunday's infinite
work machine hypothetical.
That's very funny.
Bro, it's
Do you think they just took like the
transcripts of a bunch of people's
streams and put them into chat GPT and
were like, "Figure out how to like make
these same allegations back at at the
people who are who are putting them out
here." Or figure out how to use the same
rhetoric these people are. Like I I'm
It's honestly weird. It's uncanny to
watch. bears responsibility when the
machine eventually hurts someone. And
I'm not claiming that every central
figure in all this personally did every
bad act. That would be an absurd
standard, okay? That that We would never
meet that standard, right? Like Trump
didn't personally go in and break in on
January 6th, but he still bears
responsibility.
And this is a tactic that I'm going to
show you, right? Because I have I have I
have an example of, right? And this is
what we're going to talk about Queen.
Okay, I'm sorry.
This This is where I'm going to say,
"You cannot say that I'm the person
doing the bad things and that Queen's
out and he's innocent and he did nothing
bad." You cannot do that while using
Queen's comments on you
to attack that server or denigrate me,
okay? No. No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no. Off. I'll tell you
anything Queen said that's mean or is
like use it maliciously weaponizing a
definition, I won't cut him off for it.
If I If you want me to bring it up with
him the next time I talk to him, I'll
ask him precisely what he means and I'll
clarify.
But that's as far as I'll go. I'm not
cutting him off for being mean to
people. I'm not cutting him off for
maliciously using a definition to [__]
with somebody or make a joke, okay?
Nope.
But I will I will clarify with him
exactly what he means
if you ask me to. How you doing?
Okay.
Uh Schrödinger's joke.
What is Schrödinger's joke?
It's where you make a statement, say
something, you mention a thing,
and whether or not it's a joke depends
on how it lands.
So, this is a one of their favorite
tactics that they'll do. Especially now
that they've been caught Oh, okay.
Especially now that we have the logs.
You guys remember Nikondros uh during
the Chud Logic Destiny
uh Shamoo debate, right? Before they
actually had the conversation and the
logs were just released to Twitter, that
was the go-to for Nikondros. He's like,
"It's just a joke, gang. It's just a
joke. We're just joking. We're having a
good time. It's a joke. I was posting it
as a joke. It was a joke, gang. It was a
joke."
I think he said that to me cuz he was
like embarrassed in the Discord. He
didn't say that like out in public,
right? He said that in the Discord.
>> It was a joke. It was a joke.
Because it's a it's it's where they
live. It's a Schrödinger's joke. Like if
that hadn't worked, if people had bought
that it was a joke, that would have been
the line. But no one bought the joke
because it was obviously not in the
context of what we had and it didn't go
well for him. Nikondros was exposed as a
[__] liar, right? He he was obviously
lying.
But they live in this this space, right?
It's Schrö-
Again, you were accusing him of doxxing.
No information's been posted anywhere.
That person hasn't even been contacted.
Like literally nothing happened. I don't
You are You are inventing something.
Whole claws.
How you are allowed to do this without
being called out is beyond me.
Schrödinger's joke, where they can say
whatever they like about you. They can
make any claim that they want. I'm now
so annoyed that Chud didn't pull me into
that convo.
And if people call them out or disprove
their claim,
Oh, it's just a joke. I was just joking.
We were just joking. Let me show you one
example, okay?
Give me one moment. Let me make sure I
have it up. Here we
go. Okay. Here is QueenMan. He did a
little I don't know why he posted me in
response to what Destiny tweeted, but
this is me as a pretty kitty. Okay? I'm
a pretty kitty wig.
First of all, uh just as an aside,
um I don't know why you guys think
you're going to embarrass me for posting
things that I've posted publicly. Like
if I was embarrassed about this, I
wouldn't have done it. I don't know
I don't know what you think you're going
to do here. Like yes, I dressed up as a
kitty
That's a part of the humiliation, by the
way. That's a That's like a part of them
mocking you.
Like you understand that, right? They
understand you're not embarrassed of it
and that's a part of the joke.
That's like that's literally required
for if you were embarrassed by this that
you could go, "Oh, I was just drunk and
I [__] this up and and it wouldn't be
as funny." The fact that you're willing
to go, "Actually, this was awesome. I
love this. I love doing this and this is
cool and I'll do it again." That's a
part of the joke. You forget it's just
it was funny. I was a great actor, okay?
I was very pretty kitty. This doesn't
embarrass me. But there's something like
I don't mind. Like if you're going to
like post me eating ramen noodles or
dancing or whatever. Whatever. I don't
give a [__] It's sometimes annoying
depending, but whatever.
But that's not all they do. Um let me
show you something. This was from a
couple years ago that Queenman did. Um
Hold on.
Again.
I'm just going to point out
very obvious that Wick referring to me
saying I'm doing all these evil things
and you're going to catch me.
I don't know how you're doing that
when at the same time you're going to
throw up like Queenman clips saying,
"Look at Look at how they Look at the
tactics." I need examples for me, man,
that demonstrate
>> And examples to match your multiple
examples you described. And the joke and
and and remember the defense for this
has always been, "It's just a joke."
Wick, it's just a joke, right? But they
only make that defense when I like when
I call it out. When I'm not calling it
out
you're talking to people in DMs. They're
going around and spreading the rumor
that this is actually happened. So let
me just read the tweet and we'll watch
the clip. So uh this is me replying to
Queenman and I say, "Hey, here's your
audience painting me out as someone who
engages in assault against a woman.
Lying to your audience despite that same
woman later making it clear to folks
that this was absolutely not the case."
And not just later, she was doing it at
the time, too, right? He's going to show
one part of a chat, but he won't show
the rest. We're going to get to that. Um
and then when he's called out on it, he
retreats to just jokes. Note that this
is just one part of an active campaign
to slander me and paint me to have to be
a suspect because this isn't all they've
done. This isn't all Queenman has said
on this. And he said stuff recently,
too, on his stream about me and Kinetic
Kel, right? That's what he's done. Um
he's a liar, and and worst of all
he's British. So, I don't know what the
[__] he's doing trying to make fun of
me. He's British. It's crazy. Take the
L, mate. Uh, let's bring up actually
some terrible allegations. Yeah, let's
let's watch the clip. Just watch the
clip, and you can see
>> Wow, British. He's so British. He's so
British. Got him. Got him. But, you got
him. There's actually some terrible
terrible allegations.
Absolutely horrific stuff, I got to say,
that's been brought up about
about Wicks, I'll honestly say. So,
Bucks wanted to spin pressing for
information. Let's go.
>> At Ginger Marshall, did Wicks ask for
consent prior to groping yourself?
>> And Madame Genevieve in that photo that
was posted.
As you can see here, if we get some zoom
and enhance analysis going on.
You can see here Wicks is touching what
appears to be
Madame Genevieve Touching people's legs
that you're at a party with and your
friends with. Crazy. But, here's how
they paint it.
>> He's outer thigh and knee.
And that yeah, this is this is the outer
thigh here as well. The outer thigh and
knee on Ginger Marshall. Now
obviously
we've got the response here. He did not
He did not ask. He did not say, "Ma'am,
would you mind if I touch your leg?"
before Who does that with friends?
First of all. But, you see how they're
painting it? All right? And you see how
they're clipping Ginger Marshall and
what she said? And we're going we're
going to go to what else she said, and
we're going to talk about how this
obviously was not a joke. It was
Schrödinger's joke, right? Because it's
a joke when you call them out on it, but
they're actively spreading this rumor,
right? They're actively spreading this
rumor. But, yeah. Would you touch her
leg? Now
is the sexual harassment HR meme? It is.
It is.
I said, "Tell me you wouldn't be
traumatized if Wicks touched your leg."
Come on, who here Who here can say
Who here can say they would not be
traumatized if Wicks if Wicks touched
their leg, okay? An hour-long shower and
then therapy. I'd be traumatized if
Destiny or Wicks did that, says Eddie. I
feel sick, says Hey, It's Lissie.
I'd have eight showers. I'm just
laughing at how uh Creamy's got no
gravitas back here.
Creamy's like is
such a low power level right now. It's
very funny listening to the clip like
this. Just no power level. No There's
nothing going on here. It's like
watching I'm laughing because it's it's
like watching my old streams, right?
It's very funny.
>> different loofahs.
Okay. [snorts]
Endless hot showers and years of PTSD,
especially bare leg. Yeah, I mean that's
just terrifying stuff. Really, that's
just nasty.
And it's hidden within jokes, right? The
accusation itself is hidden within kind
of laughter.
No, it's not. The jokes are literally
even even like like platonic normal
touching for people with is disgusting
coming from you.
That's the joke. You are gross. You are
gross to the level that platonic normal
touching actually seems like
off-putting. It's the HR meme is in when
a hot guy does it, it's totally fine.
When an ugly guy does it, it's actually
gross. Hello? Hello?
That's It's obvious the whole time that
it's a joke. I hope they got better than
that. These are serious allegations,
right? They're joking, quote unquote,
but they're not. Um that I'm a someone
who's harassed these women. And look,
maybe you could say that if this was
isolated, but remember Buck Swader is a
person who DM'd Mantis to for to try to
paint me as a suspect as well uh to get
her logs to paint me as someone who'd
been harassing Mantis as well, right?
This was an act of campaigning that they
did for a long long time to paint me as
a suspect that they're still doing to
this day. But yeah, this is something
that's been going on for years. And this
is a tactic that they use. Schrödinger's
joke, right? And they will make
accusations, but they will do it kind of
half-jesting. And yeah, this is what
happens. So yeah, it's a it's a big
tactic tactic that Cream uses a lot.
It's very popular, okay?
Now, here we go.
Step nine, and I see this happening in
chat, too.
Hey Twitch, I'm looking at you. Uh you
maximize
yours
and you minimize theirs. And what does
that mean?
Anything done to you,
you paint in the maximally bad light,
right? I've seen this happen on Twitter,
right? Claims by different streamers and
different people, some of them don't
stream anymore, that I have uh
that I was harassing Contra. That I was
harassing CounterPoints.
Right? What did I actually do? I
disagreed with the way was handling it
and I confronted him about it. Is that
harassment in no stretch of the
imagination? Have I been harassing
counterpoints? Quite the opposite in
fact. But because I questioned, right?
The people the person that they were
mind raping,
um I'm her I'm harassing counterpoints.
I'm stalking counterpoints. I'm going
after counterpoints. That's the
narrative that some of them are
planting, right? And they'll minimize
what they do.
And you see this all the time. They're
like, "Bro, we just have a clipping
channel."
>> Okay.
>> You are minimizing
the coordinated harassment campaign that
you have built and are targeting towards
not only Destiny, Ethan Klein,
um anyone associated with them. Dude, if
we could if we could actually do like a
coordinated psyop on like five different
streamers who have audiences in the or
on the order of like hundreds of
thousands, if we could do all of this at
the same time, then you guys should shut
the [__] up. We're like superhuman. You
guys should like actually put your head
down.
Right?
If you really believe that you should
put your head down, no?
We're We're dominating this hard with
just 100 people?
No shot. them who doesn't disavow,
um that is not just we have criticisms
and are expressing them. There's a
fundamental difference here.
And And this is what they'll do. When
you call it out and none of the other
tactics work, they can't deflect from
it, they can't distract from it, they
can't go on offense, they can't move the
goalpost.
They'll minimize it.
And they'll minimize what happens to
you, too, right? They'll minimize
And we've talked about this before,
right? But they'll minimize what happens
to you. Like all you did All I did was
dox you, bro.
And yeah, that's bad. And we disavow it.
But Destiny has done so much worse to
us.
He doxxed us.
Ah.
Double If they didn't have double
standards, they wouldn't have any
standards at all.
Be clear.
Um Desi started doxxing people before
this Discord existed.
Ugly Moe Rat
You are so stupid. Desi was doxxing
people long before this Discord ever
existed. You rat.